North Korea says it will send athletes
to the Winter Olympics in South Korea
next month
diplomats made that deal overnight
during talks in the Korean Demilitarized
Zone they were the first between the two
countries in more than two years the
south is asking the north to march
together at the Olympics opening and
closing ceremonies North Korean leader
Kim jong-un wants to be part of the
Winter Games but he has not shown any
interest in negotiating over his nuclear
program today's talks lasted for several
hours and both sides agreed to hold
future military discussions but it's
unclear what else they can't agree on
and how the negotiations will affect the
US retired Admiral sandy Winnefeld CBS
News military and homeland security
analyst is with us he was vice chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff from 2011
through 2015 before that he led the
military command responsible for
preventing air attacks on North America
Admiral good morning thank you for
joining us I mean good morning Gail Nora
and Jeff it's good to see you in the new
year oh good to see you good to see you
explain the significance of this you
know these two nations each came to the
table desperately wanting one thing in
the near term on North Korea's part they
desperately wanted the legitimacy that's
conferred by participating in the
Olympic movement it would have been
enormous Lee humiliating for them had
the Olympic spectacle been going on
right across the border and they were
not participating and it feeds their
message of you know we may have nuclear
weapons but we're a normal nation and
should be treated like that on the
South's part they desperately would like
to have a disturbance free games and
even more importantly they would like to
not have participating nations scale
back their athletes participation out of
concern for what might happen during the
game so they each came when you have two
parties come to the table and they
desperately want something for different
reasons it's really easy to reach an
agreement which which which leads to the
question Admiral are they just doing
this now so they can have sort of a safe
and happy games and then the tension
immediately returns right after you know
negotiators are always looking for a
hook they're looking for something to
break the ice and there is maybe a
little ray of sunshine
here that this might lead to something
else but I would be very cautious about
irrational exuberance here at military
exercises for example where postponed
not cancelled we still have two leaders
that like to taunt each other and we
still have a North Korea with a long
history of manipulating negotiations
like this now President Trump had said
that the talks would not have happened
between the tough between the two
countries without his tough stance do
you think he helped contribute to this
you know I don't want to take anything
away from the administration but I do
not believe that North Korea came to the
table because they were intimidated or
dragged to the table they came with a
very specific purpose in mind and that
is to regain some legitimacy out there
in the real world to avoid the
humiliation of not participating in the
games and in the process possibly cut in
a little bit to the resolve that the
international community might have
towards future sanctions so what do you
think US officials will be looking for
most closely as these two sides
communicate with each other well of
course everybody will be parsing every
single word that is said during these
negotiations they'll be choppy with
people coming in and out of the room and
the like and in particular people will
be very interested in the responses that
North Korea gives when asked about the
potential for future negotiations
regarding the nuclear program or other
military matters got to be careful not
to read too much into what the other
side says but that would be very very
closely examined Admiral when I was in
South Korea earlier this year and spoke
with president moon he had talked about
that he wants to sit knee to knee with
Kim jong-un to have these bilateral
talks the concern that some experts have
raised however is that while that's
happening though the north will use that
time to continue to build up their
missile and nuclear capability is our
intelligence good enough to know what
they're doing well you know looking into
North Korea is looking through a glass
darkly it's a very opaque country it's
very very difficult to get intelligence
there we've known for some time because
the intelligence community told us that
North Korea is interested in developing
a strategic nuclear weapons program and
we reacted accordingly so there are no
real big surprises there the only
surprises are a little
timing things maybe they do things a
little faster than we had expected but I
would call that in intelligence
imperfection not intelligence failure
we've known they've wanted this program
for a long time
all right Admiral thank you very much
for your time very welcome thank you